with cs Go's heavily rumored Source 2
update on the horizon the community is
in speculation about a lot of things
matchmaking tick rates how it'll affect
skins whether it'll be a full-fledged
operation
Etc but there is one thing that is on
everybody's Minds
Maps will Tuscan make it in and if so
what will it replace considering that
right now the least played maps are the
newest ones there is a dream that could
become a reality and that is
are we finally getting rid of Mirage
all right so before we start milking
Source 2 for even more viewership I must
plug our merch yes we the scoring Sports
have merch head over to
shop.thescore.com and check out our
Esports collection it's super well made
I wear it all the time buy us aside so
grab some for yourself or for a friend
with Source 2 likely on the way a thing
that has come up a lot as of late is
maps and speculation as to what will be
in it after the ostensibly impending
update now to be clear I'm not talking
about which Maps will be in Source 2 in
general it is safe to assume that at
some point they'll all either get remade
or ported directly from the current
engine I'm just talking about what'll
actually be in active duty the reason
for this is that we haven't had an
operation for like a year and a half so
there's a fairly decent chance that if
and when Source 2 does come along it'll
bring a bunch of content with it among
said content may very well be a new
addition to the competitive map Pool and
right now the leading Contender is
Tuscan for those who didn't play Tuscan
or CPL Mill back in older iterations of
Counter-Strike it is a very old very
famous map the current CS Go version was
in the works for quite some time and was
put into matchmaking back in August of
2022 and it's
fine b-site is a bit of a nightmare in
my opinion since it's just so so ratty
but it is a cool uniquely structured
Legacy map that I and many others would
really like to see the pros get a crack
at so that it can get better the
question is assuming it does come into
active duty and that valve keep the
rotation at seven total
what will it replace now historically
valve have opted to keep things
objective by simply removing the least
played map in the rotation last time it
was dust 2 the time before that it was
trained you see right now the map seeing
the least amount of play are the newest
valve can't take out Anubis since they
literally just put it in and ancient was
only inserted into competitive play two
years ago it's also come a long way
since then and his valves sort of pet
project map since they essentially made
it in secret and then surprised Everyone
by throwing it straight into active duty
three months after release despite it
being in not so great a place since then
it's gotten way better and I think for
valve it serves as a sort of proof of
concept that their own in-house Maps can
be made released thrown into active duty
and whipped into shape without a ton of
Pomp and Circumstance suffice it to say
they're not gonna take out ancient but
the third least played map vertigo
excuse me vertigoat
is where things get interesting you see
replacing cash with vertigo back in 2019
was valve's first ever attempt at
forcefully shaking up the map Pool
having never been played in competitive
Counter-Strike vertigo's inclusion was
very controversial bring back cash bring
back cash maybe just update cash a
little bit I know that FM Pawn's doing
that just get it done and bring it back
don't waste time with vertigo to be fair
app that Naf was on back in
July of 2019 is very different from the
vertigo that we know and love today
and while there are certain competitors
who regard the map as
not so great except the thing is with
vertigo like the map just sucks the
numbers do show that over time vertigo
has not only reached a stable pick rate
but is actually one of the most balanced
maps in Counter-Strike so why am I
saying all of this well aside from the
fact that I love vertigo and want to
fight for it I'm trying to illustrate
that the experiment that valve conducted
back in 2019 worked I'm not even saying
that vertigo couldn't stand to see a
change or two I'm just saying that to
pull the rip cord now and take it out
entirely would be a really disappointing
way for its journey to end especially
considering that there are other maps
that people have been whining about for
much much longer in addition to being
the most played map in the history of
professional CS go Mirage has become
absurdly
unacceptably overplayed in pugs there
are countless memes concerning what a
mirage simulator face it has become and
it sucks in my opinion any map being
this much of an immovable pillar is a
hindrance to the growth of the game
never mind getting kids in a face of pug
to play a new map I can't even get them
to play three rounds of Anubis in
retakes before saying this map and
rtving our asses onto Mirage for the
millionth time now not everyone feels
this way in fact Mirage is widely
regarded as the closest thing CS go has
to a perfect map and look I admit it is
a very well designed map
would it use a few touch-ups like how
B-side is a little too ratty and how if
you're standing cat you can effectively
defend two bomb sites at once
yeah I think there's a little bit of
work to be done there but on the whole
it's a very good map it is also very
stale and criminally overplayed this is
in my opinion the best opportunity valve
have ever had to take out either Mirage
or Inferno I actually don't care which
one just please for the love of God take
one of them out those who know me know
that I think very very little of Inferno
and regard it as easily the worst map in
active duty so yeah would I ever so
slightly prefer to see Inferno taken out
of a mirage yes but I recognize that the
vast majority of players would rather
see Mirage taken out given house stale
and overplayed it is now there is no
question that a valve took out Mirage
tomorrow it would send the entire player
base into a frenzy pugs as we know them
would enter an existential crisis and a
ramp demons everywhere would start
hemorrhaging ELO until they learned new
maps which is precisely why they should
do it Mirage has been in CS go since
2013. it is the only map to never be
taken out of active duty is the only map
to be played at all 15 CS go majors and
is home to some of the greatest plays
that our game has ever seen
I know I know run the jumping off much
more utility to work with here he comes
once again the first base is a trend
he's gonna hit the ground there it's
cold
what is it going on right now how does
he do this look I get that y'all like it
but it's time man no map should be this
Untouchable all right if dust two can
get taken out twice
anything can will they take Mirage out
unfortunately
I don't find it very likely the
community is just way too obsessed with
it and while I don't think they'll touch
nuke since it's way too crucial to the
pro scene and is actually the best map
in Counter-Strike I think that overpass
is a much easier Target and to be fair I
think there is a real case to be made
that overpass should go since it was
first introduced back in 2013 overpass
has gone from an absolute dumpster fire
to one of the best maps in CS go it had
a super sick super important run but it
has gotten really stable and CT sided in
ways that just aren't fun to play or
watch I swear if I see one more Monster
Pop get squashed by a jail spray down
I'm gonna fall asleep smack dab in the
middle of the connector rotate do I
think overpass should go before Mirage
no
but a man can dream anyway I don't
actually think that valve will take out
either Mirage or Inferno at least not
this time around because quite frankly I
don't think they have the courage but I
will still be profoundly disappointed if
they don't that said once overpass is
gone
the competition is going to look a lot
stiffer they can't take out nuke since
it's way too good and way too crucial to
the pro scene plus it and Inferno were
already taken out in reworked some years
ago which means
look alive Mirage of course they could
just say it and take out vertigo at
which point I would pretty much lose
every last bit of faith I have in valve
and scream into a pillow anyway
let's hope it doesn't come to that and
see what happens with Source 2 first
maps are a very tricky thing in csgo the
community is so divided on what's good
and what's not and so resistant to
change that sometimes it can become
suffocating surely we can all agree that
whether you like Mirage or don't in
order for Counter-Strike to stay healthy
it needs to stay fresh so let's inject
some freshness into it
and take out Mirage any extra thoughts
look man for all this bite all this
hoopla I made I would actually rather
they take out Inferno that's my hot take
I actually honestly just want to see
Inferno go
inferno's such a
Escape dude I would really rather take
it out but I think that the community
has become two Stockholm syndromes